in this video we'll talk about
parkinson's disease
parkinson's disease is a age-related
neurodegenerative disease which affect
the movements
this disease is not really new because
it was earlier discovered by james
parkinson in 1817 he described this kind
of situation as shaking policy
when we look at the symptoms it would be
clear why it is known as shaking policy
the major symptoms of parkinson includes
shuffling gate and uncoordinated
movement there is always trimmer
associated with this disease
the streamer is persistent and tremor in
hands occur even at rest and that is why
probably he named named this disease as
shaking palsy
other symptoms includes stooping posture
musk face reduced arm swing flexed elbow
and wrist etc
parkinson is pretty common these days
among aging population
the optimal
age where parkinson's develop is beyond
60 and it is more prevalent in males
compared to the females
there are genetic factors and
environmental factors associated with
the disease progression
genetic factors includes mutation at
least described in 20 different genes
which are associated with various
cellular processes
environmental risk factors includes
pesticides heavy metal toxicity etc
let's talk about the hallmarks of
parkinson disease parkinson's disease is
characterized by lewy body formation and
the death of dopaminergic neuron in the
substantia [ __ ] let's talk about the
pathology in bit more details
there are characteristic neurons present
dopaminergic neurons present in our
basal ganglia known as uh
substantia [ __ ] specific dopaminergic
neurons the substantia [ __ ] region is
actually present just below the
subthalamic nucleus
now substantia [ __ ] in latin means
black substances
that means these neurons are black in
appearance the reason why they are black
is because they are dopaminergic and
they produce neuromelanin
in parkinson patient one can see
clear reduction in the number of these
neurons and they probably die
so one of the key
aspect of parkinson pathology is protein
aggregation
and the
protein aggregation of alpha cyanuclean
is thought to be one important cause of
parkinson's disease
alpha-synuclein
aggregations are actually forming lewy
body which is one of the hallmark of
parkinson's disease
mutations in alpha-synuclein gene has
been associ has been found to be
associated with the parkinson disease
missense mutation in this gene can cause
classic parkinson like phenotype
there are duplications and replications
in this gene which is also associated
with parkinson's disease progression
now the normally this alpha-synuclein
protein
is really important though the function
is not fully understood this particular
protein is found in different cell types
including neurons and neurons of all
over the brain
so this particular
protein occurs in the cytosol possibly
also in mitochondria and nucleus
this is this protein is reported to be
involved in synaptic vesicle dynamics
mitochondrial function intracellular
trafficking and it might have a
chaperone-like activity
now let's look at what happens during
lewy body formation
so louis body formation
initiates with unfolded or misfolded
alpha-synuclein protein
this alpha-synuclein protein forms
oligomers these oligomers combine with
each other to form fibrils and these
fibrils associate with each other to
form these lewy body-like formation so
the intracellular dewey body is a
characteristic feature of parkinson's
disease and this can be visualized from
the postmortem brains as well
now parkinson's disease progression has
different phases
and these are known as brack stage one
where you can see autonomic and
olfactory disturbances but the lewy body
is not spreading the brain all over
and louis body can be found in mono
monoamine aminergic and cholinergic
neurons of the brain stem at this stage
in stage 3 and 4 there is sleep and
motor related disturbances and
the alpha-synuclein aggregates have
spread in the basal part of the
forebrain and also in the midbrain
in the advanced stage that means stage
five and six there is emotional and
cognitive disturbances and in this stage
we can see alpha synuclein to be present
in the limbic system as well as in the
cortex
now though we know few
aspects of parkinson's disease pathology
there are many questions which are
unanswered one such question is why
selectively the dopaminergic neuron die
in parkinson disease why not a
cholinergic neuron or glutamatergic
neuron dies
also another question which hunts the
scientists is why dopaminergic neurons
are more susceptible to form lewy body
what is the intrinsic factor that makes
these neurons more vulnerable
one such answer could be a disbalance in
proteostasis whenever there is misfolded
proteins in the cell
there are autophagy mechanisms which try
to clear up or recycle these senile
proteins
but if there is a error in these
autophagy system
there could be accumulation of these
unfolded or misfolded proteins which
might lead to the disease progression
now recently scientists found there is a
gut brain connection in parkinson
disease
how is that
so first of all it has been seen that in
parkinson patient the gut microbiome is
heavily altered compared to a healthy
individual of same age
that means maybe it could be a cause of
the disease or maybe a consequence
anyway scientists did a fascinating
experiment where they took the gut
microbiome or they isolated the gut
microbiome from parkinson patient and
they
put this gut microbiome into a mouse who
doesn't have any gut microbiome
and after injecting this gut microbiome
into the mouse intestine this mouse
shows characteristic defects like motor
defects inflammation which are pretty
much pretty much
indicative of parkinson's disease
that's pretty interesting recently it
has been shown
that the initiation of parkinson's
disease could be starting in the gut
because when they seeded a portion of
alpha-synuclein aggregates in the
intestine they found that these
alpha-synuclein travels long way back to
the brain with the help of the vagus
nerve and then they spread all over the
brain and this happens in order of
several years
so these findings really add up value to
our understanding towards parkinson's
disease
also there are other factors which are
associated with parkinson's disease
could be also causal for the disease and
one such factor is mitochondrial
dysfunction mitochondrial dysfunction
leads to many problems and there are
several pesticides which contains
rotinon and this rotinon is a complex
one inhibitor and rotanon is known to
cause parkinson disease or it's a risk
factor for the parkinson's disease
development that brings out the
mitochondrial connection with this
disease development other than that
there is increased ross production in
parkinson's brain so the neurons produce
more ross and the raw scavenging system
is probably
not working that well at this particular
situation so this ross production and
mitochondrial dysfunction together might
lead to the disease pathology
now let's talk about
the microglial activation other than
these symptoms recently scientists
thinks that microglia might come into
the picture and they might be a reason
by which the dopaminergic neuron died
they kind of destroy the neurons
let's talk about the diagnosis option
so diagnosis of parkinson disease is
kind of not i mean there is no absolute
diagnosis test
but with looking at the characteristic
motor defects a doctor can guess or kind
of
think of
this particular disease
so
when the doctor suspects about parkinson
they always
ask for mri imaging so the substantia
[ __ ] can be visible and the loss of
neurons can be visible in mri imaging or
let's say in the pet scan
let's talk about the treatment option
again there is no cure for parkinson
existing medication can help to improve
the situation but there is no absolute
cure it can increase the life expectancy
can improve the cognition but it cannot
cure the disease
these medications involve
substances like
levodopa
[Music]
which is
which is a particular
compound which can be utilized to
generate dopamine so in parkinson's
disease there is a lack of dopamine in
the synapses and that can be overcome by
administration of liver dopa there is
also dopamine receptor agonist because
ultimately dopamine works by activating
these dopamine receptors
so this dopamine receptor agonist work
similar to our dopamine
now there are other drugs or medications
which prevents the dopamine degradation
and thereby making dopamine persistent
in the synaptic cleft
so all these medications are kind of
useful for treat the symptoms of
parkinson it can improve
the cognitive output
but it cannot treat the disease so just
to summarize treatment option includes
medications like levodopa
it also includes monoamine oxidase
inhibitors dopamine receptor agonists
and
comp inhibitors
now there are some uh advanced stage of
disease progression where there is
severe cognitive defects and there is
problem with brain stimulation so
surgical implantations like deep brain
stimulation might help in that advanced
stage of disease progression
so i hope this video is useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up all the notes associated with this
topic can be found in my facebook page
and the facebook page link is provided
in the description
there are a lot of dynamic notes flash
cards which would help your revision
process
do check it out don't forget to like
share and subscribe let me know in the
comment whether you enjoyed this
detailed video
support me on patreon if you are indian
viewer you can support me in
bim upi app my courses are present in an
academy using my code ap10 you can get a
10 discount see you in next video